hello and welcome to this video M
Western again ok I'm playing this slide
oh it takes it interesting how d5
couldn't be six is interesting or III
couldn't be six spoon what is happening
here if I just do this I see trying to
know okay so he's basically saying that
if I take it it's not be five hmm no one
I'd be five animals might be five
there's queen bee six maybe take on it I
can take on f2 and she 24 SS this is
enough but you can check on d6 well
that's not clear that it does sup this
much ok very funny 95 Queen B 6 Quincy
seven I can take f.2d forecheck malice
is a small and enough in so let's not
let's not happening i guess now be fine
I can also take on f2 a king takes Queen
v6 check but he has 94 and then I
actually have an e5 Wow now interesting
complications here and twin be 60 is the
principal move so let's go for it what
happens here if I take F to Queen takes
Queen B tool
okay is there something great I don't
see it they can really sacrifice tough
and check made me also we'll see yeah
the London system sometimes you get
interesting positions there if both
sides yet somehow want to mix it up you
will probably get something funky yep
let's see what he's doing so I have to
that rap now and now yeah it was also
hanging if I just take the pawn voice
that the too much I just grabbed it 94
and then take on detour
I need better move or I know I think
taking this good book takes is Quincy
one which puts them into sometimes I
self-penned almost nine to six now the
question is if you can do something like
Bishop d3 sacrifice the house but I
always have this check so don't think it
should work Bishop d3 clean edge one
that that might work with Bishop f7 and
stuff moon yeah I think I better give
the check here jack no f5 or something
like that it takes rook takes this
should be okay
how many pools do actually have three
pawns right yeah I have aged six and
potentially also the caption here that
ruckus lose okay probably h6 first you
before I do anything else his king is
also in danger this is the thing that
makes me quite optimistic yourself to to
defend 33 points is also pretty nice
okay so i take f3 check check
look at three Queen takes Queen g5 check
pawn takes check I take take it's got
this check Quinn Quinn g6 maybe I cannot
sell not sure I'll check
ok everyone maybe but I have Queen III
that pins the night if I get an e5
before things it's just over one down to
one minute I when you see that now check
maybe I should have checked first anyway
that was just as a chick
think that should be so dangerous 95 95
oakley 52 in f1 yeah your friends Queen
a force a great time morning printf Oh
made plain pretty strong
check-check
white resigned oh yeah I know maybe that
didn't work what he did in the opening
but I I don't know it was very very
tough so this this ok 9 p-5 didn't work
I have Queen a5 actually this is much
easier I was thinking this but I think
this also works check this this and this
I'm glad this was my my calculation
actually that is Chinese the defender
thought I'm winning which is at least
this is confirmed by the computer very
nicely but it's a completely completely
unnecessary line as after 95 I just have
create five until Black is just a lot
better by normal means but this is this
is good right it's difficult for him now
to defend all everything Jan a computer
says just just gives black of school
full wynia but it's still not not that
that's simple for you must player you
always yeah kind of concerned that some
attack happens yeah the computer
mercilessly wants to take this yeah I
wasn't sure you know this kind of stuff
check I have this one ok ok ok ok ok
yeah then everything's fine I didn't see
that one coming Jan I can actually take
the route but this is not bad I mean
have three poems up and hear the
position is reasonably safe
and here i think i can take every year
but I wasn't completely sure yeah like
no not they actually yeah here there was
one position where I thought I can take
f3 yeah here jack actually I didn't
really look at King takes to be honest I
was only thinking about Jack this looked
fine yeah I wasn't sure d5 plan looks
good yeah i can check finally use the
pawns and okay blonde at the bishop but
it probably doesn't have much either
anyway I mean it's the right word this
is what i was seeing an e4 and i thought
i'm winning threatening check yeah black
black winsome the opening just just
didn't work out well for white okay well
thanks for watching